why is it that so many people come to
America within 10 years they have more
money than the people that were born in
America the way we've ran America if the
American Born kids are kids of these
families they're the kids of the
families that spoiled them in America
there's no more earning things in
America just hand it out to them we're
printing money left and right we're
giving away income to people left and
right we're making life easier we're
incentivizing the wrong things do you
know in 1940 in America what percentage
of kids were born to single mothers 4%
is the number you know what that number
is today over 40% Shia 50% you mean to
tell me we went from
1944% to today so what happened there
policies by FDR Social Security and
incentives of taking care of single
mothers then Lyndon Johnson in 1965 took
it to a whole different level mothers
are sitting there saying the more kids I
have the more entitled programs I get
great why would I get married the
incentive programs America set up
totally screwed everything up